Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. The Californian city of Stanford lies in the northwest corner of Santa Clara County, just under an hour's drive from San Francisco. Covering an inland area of 2.8 square miles, Stanford is adjacent to Palo Alto, one of the principal cities of the affluent and progressive
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。加利福尼亚州的斯坦福市位于圣克拉拉县的西北角，距离旧金山不到一小时的车程。斯坦福占地 2.8 平方英里，毗邻帕洛阿尔托，而帕洛阿尔托是富裕且进步的
Silicon Valley, which has served as an incubator for many prominent and influential technological enterprises over the years, including Apple, Google, Facebook and Tesla. Stanford is home to the prestigious 8000-acre Stanford University, a private, co-educational and non-denominational college and research institution. Many of the city's residents are students or faculty members who live on or around campus in a range of accommodations, including gulmitries, co-ops, row houses, fraternities, sororities, single-family homes and condominiums. Established in 1885, the university was founded by railroad magnate and California
硅谷的主要城市之一。多年来，硅谷一直是许多著名且具有影响力的科技企业的孵化器，包括苹果、谷歌、Facebook 和特斯拉。斯坦福拥有占地 8000 英亩、声誉卓著的斯坦福大学，这是一所私立、男女同校且无宗派之分的综合性大学和研究机构。该市的许多居民都是学生或教职员工，他们住在校园内或周边的各种宿舍中，包括宿舍楼、合作公寓、排屋、兄弟会住宅、姐妹会住宅、独栋住宅和共管公寓。该大学建于 1885 年，由铁路大亨兼加利福尼亚州
Senator Leland Stanford and his wife Jane, in memory of their only child, Leland Jr, who died of typhoid fever at age 15. The land began as a stock farm with oak-dotted fields and soon developed into one of the largest university campuses in the United States. Despite sustaining heavy damage from two separate earthquakes in 1906 and 1989, the university has managed to maintain its original California mission architecture from the late 1800s, characterized by embellished yellow sandstone, long, low and wide colonnades, open arches and red terracotta-tiled roofs.
参议员利兰·斯坦福和他的妻子简为纪念他们 15 岁时因伤寒去世的独子小利兰而创立。这片土地最初是一个点缀着橡树田地的股票农场，不久便发展成为美国最大的大学校园之一。尽管在 1906 年和 1989 年的两场独立大地震中遭受了严重破坏，但该大学仍成功保留了其 19世纪末最初的加利福尼亚教会建筑风格，其特点是饰有精美图案的黄色砂岩、长而低矮宽阔的柱廊、开放式拱门以及红色的西班牙陶瓦屋顶。
At the heart of the campus is the main quadrangle, the university's oldest structure. Stretching over 17 acres, the main quad is reached via a mile-long palm tree-lined road and has an inner and outer section, both of which feature sprawling lawns, courtyards and interconnected buildings housing various departments, classrooms and administration offices. Regarded as a national center for research, Stanford features more than 120 research institutes exploring a range of topics, from particle physics to international studies. Given its proximity to Silicon Valley and its impressive academic and athletic
校园的核心是主方庭，这是该大学最古老的建筑。主方庭占地超过 17 英亩，可通过一条长达一英里、两旁种满棕榈树的道路到达，分为内庭和外庭，两部分都设有广阔的草坪、庭院和相互连接的建筑，容纳了各个系所、教室和行政办公室。斯坦福被视为国家级研究中心，拥有 120 多个研究机构，探索从粒子物理学到国际研究等一系列课题。鉴于其毗邻硅谷及其令人印象深刻的学术和体育
performance records, it is renowned as one of the top universities of the world. Many students go on to have illustrious careers in their field of expertise, with past alumni including Nobel laureates, Pulitzer Prize winners and Presidential Medal of Freedom recipients. 150,000 visitors are drawn to the famed grounds annually to explore its many features, including eateries, shops and gardens, as well as a stadium, golf course, satellite dish and church. Hiking trails around the campus outskirts offer views of the rolling countryside and attract by more than 50,000 visitors a year.
表现记录，它被誉为世界顶尖大学之一。许多学生在各自的专业领域拥有辉煌的职业生涯，过去的校友包括诺贝尔奖得主、普利策奖得主和总统自由勋章获得者。这里每年吸引 15 万名游客前来探索其众多特色，包括餐馆、商店和花园，以及体育场、高尔夫球场、卫星天线和教堂。校园边缘的远足小径可欣赏到起伏的乡村美景，每年吸引超过 5 万名游客。
In the early 1970s, just over 11,000 students were enrolled at Stanford University, and the counter-culture movement that had started in the mid-1960s was still a major aspect of college life. Students fighting for social and political change would often stage protests, sit-ins and formed community action groups for issues such as racism, women's liberation and gay rights. Leslie Marie Perlov graduated from Stanford in 1972 with a bachelor's degree in history. By the beginning of the following year, the 21-year-old was working as a clerk at the North Santa Clara County Law Library in Palo Alto. Leslie hoped to become a lawyer and had recently been accepted into law school at the University of Pennsylvania, though classes had yet to begin.
20世纪 70 年代初，斯坦福大学招收的学生刚过 1.1 万名，始于 60 年代中期的反文化运动仍然是大学生活的一个重要方面。为争取社会和政治变革而奋斗的学生经常举行抗议活动、静坐示威，并针对种族主义、妇女解放和同性恋权利等问题成立了社区行动小组。莱斯利·玛丽·佩洛夫于 1972 年毕业于斯坦福大学，获得历史学学士学位. 到次年初，这位 21 岁的姑娘正在帕洛阿尔托的北圣克拉拉县法律图书馆担任职员。莱斯利希望成为一名律师，最近已被宾夕法尼亚大学法学院录取，尽管课程尚未开始。
At 3 p.m. on Tuesday, February 13, Leslie left work for the day, driving off in her 1972 Orange Chevrolet Nova. Her co-workers presumed she was heading directly to her home in the Los Altos Hills, where she lived with her widowed mother Florence. But Leslie never arrived. Leslie always called ahead to let her mother know if she was running late. But by nightfall, Florence still hadn't heard from her. Overcome with worry, she reported her daughter missing. As the search for Leslie commenced, her friends contemplated her possible whereabouts, and suggested that she might have gone to the wooded foothills of the Santa Cruz Mountains in Stanford South. The scenic area was popular with hikers and joggers, and as Leslie loved to
2 月 13 日星期二下午 3 点，莱斯利下班离开，驾驶着她那辆 1972 年产的橙色雪佛兰新星汽车驶离。她的同事们以为她正径直前往她在洛斯阿尔托斯山的家，她与守寡的母亲弗洛伦斯一起住在那里。但莱斯利再也没有到达。莱斯利如果晚归，总是会提前打电话通知母亲。但到了夜幕降临，弗洛伦斯仍然没有她的消息。她焦急万分，于是报警女儿失踪。随着对莱斯利的搜寻展开，她的朋友们推测了她可能去的地方，并暗示她可能去了斯坦福南部圣克鲁斯山的树木繁茂的山麓。这个风景优美的地区深受徒步旅行者和慢跑者的喜爱，而且由于莱斯利喜欢
paint, it was thought that she may have gone there looking for a picturesque landscape to capture as a gift for her mother. At 10 o'clock that night, police scanning the foothills of Old Page Mill Road on the southern cusp of the university campus discovered Leslie's Chevrolet abandoned at the gate to an old quarry, just off the Interstate 280 exit. The car was in operable condition, but its key was missing. Leslie's blue shoes and part of the blue outfit she had been wearing that day were found inside. Officers immediately suspected foul play, as Florence Perlov had made it clear that her daughter had never done anything like this before. An off-duty Palo Alto policeman had sighted Leslie's car parked at the same location
绘画，人们认为她可能去那里寻找风景如画的风景，以便画下来作为送给母亲的礼物。当晚 10 点，在大学校园南端的老帕页米尔路 foothills 巡逻的警察在高速公路 280 号出口附近的一个旧采石场大门旁发现了被遗弃的莱斯利的雪佛兰汽车。汽车状况良好，但钥匙不见了。车内找到了莱斯利的蓝色鞋子以及她当天穿的一套蓝色服装的一部分。警官们立即怀疑有谋杀嫌疑，因为弗洛伦斯·佩洛夫曾明确表示她的女儿以前从未做过这样的事情。一名休班的帕洛阿尔托警察曾在相同地点
four hours earlier at approximately 6pm. He was passing by the area when he observed Leslie in her car speaking to a young man with long, sandy-coloured hair who was standing by her window. A beige or grey-coloured car, presumably belonging to the man, was parked nearby. Over the following days, an intensive search of the old quarry was carried out. The landscape consisted of tree-lined, semi-rural roads, pockets of dense woodland, long stretches of grassy pastures, and steep hillside. The canine unit conducted a ground search, but was unable to detect Leslie's scent beyond her vehicle. At about 10.15am on Thursday, February 15, a police helicopter scanning the area caught
四小时前（大约下午 6 点）看到过莱斯利的汽车停在那里。他路过该地区时，看到莱斯利坐在车里，正和车窗旁站着的一名留着长长沙金色头发的年轻男子说话。一辆米色或灰色的小汽车（推测属于该男子）停在附近。在随后的几天里，对旧采石场进行了密集的搜查。该地区的景观包括绿树成荫的半乡村道路、大片的茂密林地、绵长的草地和陡峭的山坡。警犬队进行了地面搜查，但未能检测到莱斯利在车外的气味。2 月 15 日星期四上午 10 点 15 分左右，一架在空中搜寻的警用直升机捕捉到了
sight of something down below. Officers were sent to the location and discovered the body of a man with a severe chest wound and a sawn-off shotgun in his hand. It was initially believed that the man was linked to Leslie's disappearance, though a connection was quickly ruled out by the police. When he was identified as 24-year-old Palo Alto resident and former Stanford University student, Mark Rospold, a coroner concluded Mark had died the day after Leslie vanished and ruled his death a suicide. The discovery of his remains in the area was a mere coincidence. The following day of Friday the 16th, authorities on horseback searching unkempt wooded pastures
下方的情况。警官们被派往该地点，发现了一具男子的尸体，其胸部有严重伤口，手中拿着一支短管散农炮。最初人们认为该男子与莱斯利的失踪有关，但警方很快排除了这种联系。当他被确认身份为 24 岁的帕洛阿尔托居民、前斯坦福大学学生马克·罗斯波尔德时，验尸官得出结论，马克在莱斯利失踪的第二天死亡，并将他的死因裁定为自杀。在当地发现他的遗体纯属巧合。随后的 16 日星期天，骑马搜寻杂草丛生的林木牧场的当局
west of Leslie's vehicle came across her body laying face down under an oak tree. Her blue skirt had been pulled up around her waist and her pantyhose had been removed and stuffed into her mouth. It appeared as though Leslie's attacker had intended to rape her, but had been unable to carry out the act when she put up a fight. During the struggle, he used the multicoloured scarf Leslie was wearing to strangle her to death. A coroner determined Leslie's time of death as late afternoon on Tuesday, February 13, several hours after she was last seen alive. There was no sign of a struggle or drag marks along the path to where her body was found, leading investigators to believe she had walked
在莱斯利汽车西侧发现她的尸体面朝下躺在一棵橡树下。她的蓝色裙子被拉到腰部以上，连裤袜被脱下并塞进嘴里。看起来莱斯利袭击者的本意是强奸她，但在她反抗时未能实施这一行为。在搏斗过程中，他用莱斯利佩戴的多色围巾将她勒死。验尸官确定莱斯利的死亡时间为 2 月 13 日星期二下午晚些时候，即她最后一次被看到活着的几小时后。通往发现她尸体的小路沿途没有搏斗或拖拽的痕迹，这让调查人员相信她是自愿走到该地区的，或者没有感到任何危险。警官们花了好几天时间从犯罪现场收集物理证据，这些证据被送往萨克拉门托的国家犯罪实验室进行分析。然而，DNA 分析技术还要过十年才会出现，收集到的任何东西都无法立即识别嫌疑人。
to the area of her own accord or without sensing any danger. Officers spent days collecting physical evidence from the crime scene which was sent to the state crime lab in Sacramento for analysis. However, DNA profiling was still a decade away and nothing obtained could immediately identify a suspect. A special task force comprised of 15 deputies from the Santa Clara County Sheriff's Department was assigned to investigate Leslie's murder full-time and spent the weekend following up on numerous leads. One passerby claimed to have seen a group of Stanford University students near the side of the murder laid on Tuesday afternoon. Another reported seeing a woman walking with a man up the hill from the abandoned quarry. None of these inquiries generated any
由圣克拉拉县警长办公室的 15 名副警长组成的一个特别工作组被指派全职调查莱斯利的谋杀案，并度过了整个周末，跟进大量线索。一名路人声称在周二下午看到一群斯坦福大学学生在谋杀现场附近。另一名路人报告说看到一名女子和一个男人从废弃的采石场 uphill 走来。这些调查都没有产生任何
results and, despite requests, the blonde-haired man, witnessed speaking to Leslie at the quarry gate by the off-duty police officer, never came forward. By the ninth day of the investigation, over 1,300 work hours had gone into the case but not a single clue or suspect had emerged. The task force was gradually whittled down to just two part-time officers. By April 8, 1973, the San Francisco Examiner newspaper was reporting that there was little chance that Leslie's murder would ever be solved. On Sunday, March 24, 1974, Janet Ann Taylor was having dinner at a friend's place on the Stanford University campus when she announced that it was time for her to leave.
结果，尽管有呼吁，但那位被休班警察目击到在采石场大门与莱斯利交谈的金发男子从未主动现身。到调查的第九天，已有 1,300 多个工时投入到此案中，但没有出现一条线索或嫌疑人。工作组逐渐缩减至仅剩两名兼职警官。到 1973 年 4 月 8 日，《旧金山考察报》报道称，莱斯利谋杀案永远破获的可能性微乎其微。1974 年 3 月 24 日星期日，珍妮特·安·泰勒正在斯坦福大学校园内的一个朋友家吃晚饭，当时她宣布她该走了。
Janet lived in a cabin in nearby La Honda and wanted to get home to feed her two pet dopamine pinches and let them out for a run. The 21-year-old had recently attended Canada College in nearby Redwood City and had taken time out of her studies to work with the Stanford Research Institute and a local photography studio, and had just started a new job as a teletypist with a marine weather forecasting service in Palo Alto. Janet had strong family ties to Stanford University. Her father, Charles Chuck Taylor, was a star football player for Stanford in 1942 and went on to become the school's head football coach and athletic director. Janet elected the Hitchhike home, even though it wasn't a long journey from the campus to her
珍妮特住在附近拉洪达的一个小木屋里，想回家喂她两只宠物多巴胺捏捏，并放它们出去跑跑。这位 21 岁的女孩最近曾就读于附近红木城的卡纳达学院，并抽出时间在斯坦福研究所和当地一家摄影工作室工作，刚刚在帕洛阿尔托的一家海洋天气预报服务机构找到了一份电传打字员的新工作。珍妮特与斯坦福大学有着深厚的家族联系。她的父亲查尔斯·查克·泰勒是斯坦福大学 1942 年的明星橄榄球运动员，后来成为该校的主教练兼体育总监。珍妮特选择搭便车回家，尽管从校园到她家并不是一段很长的旅程。
house. Her friends begged her to reconsider and stay overnight, but the strong-willed, independent Janet dismissed their concerns. At 7.05pm, she was spotted trying to hitch a ride at the intersection of Mayfield Avenue and Hunapero-Sara Boulevard south of the university. By 7.35pm, she was gone. The next morning, a milk delivery driver traveling across a bridge on Sand Hill Road, three miles west from Stanford University, caught sight of a young woman's body in a roadside ditch. Bruzmarks around her neck matched the design on her knitted turtleneck sweater, suggesting something had been pressed hard against it.
她的朋友们恳求她重新考虑并留宿，但坚强、独立的珍妮特对他们的担忧置之不理。晚上 7 点 05 分，她被发现在大学南部梅菲尔德大道和胡纳佩罗-萨拉大道的交叉口试图搭便车。到晚上 7 点 35 分，她已经不见了。第二天早上，一名驾驶送奶车穿过斯坦福大学以西三英里桑德希尔路上一座桥梁的送奶司机发现路边沟里有一具年轻女性的尸体。她脖子上的淤青与她针织高领毛衣上的图案相吻合，表明有什么东西被用力压在上面。
Meanwhile, Janet Taylor had failed to show up to work that day, causing her colleagues to become increasingly concerned. Janet's roommate had also noticed her unexplained absence and called the friends she'd had dinner with the evening prior. News reports were spreading about the discovery of the woman's body, and consumed with a feeling of unease, Janet's friends contacted the sheriff's office. Following this, authorities reached out to her parents and asked them to identify the body. Janet's parents confirmed that the victim was their daughter. She was mostly clothed except for her raincoat, belt and shoes, which were scattered every quarter mile along the roadside from her body.
与此同时，珍妮特·泰勒当天没有去上班，这让她的同事们越来越担心。珍妮特室友也注意到了她莫名其妙的失踪，并打电话给前一天晚上她一起吃过晚饭的朋友。关于发现女尸的新闻报道正在流传，珍妮特的朋友们心中充满了不安的感觉，于是联系了警长办公室。在此之后，当局联系了她的父母，并要求他们辨认尸体。珍妮特的父母确认受害者是他们的女儿。她身上穿着衣服，唯独雨衣、腰带和鞋子不见了，这些东西从她的尸体所在处开始，每隔四分之一英里散落在路边。
There was no evidence of rape, though investigators suspected the crime was sexually motivated. They believed the perpetrator had picked Janet up the previous night under the guise of offering her the lift she desired, before attacking and killing her in his vehicle. He then disposed of her body into possessions along the stretch of road where she was later discovered. Janet had been hitchhiking less than a mile from where Leslie Perlov's car was discovered abandoned 13 months prior, and their bodies were found two miles apart. Both young women had been partially undressed, strangled and to left barefoot. Despite the parallels between the two murders, an inspector for San Mateo County Sheriff's
没有强奸的证据，不过调查人员怀疑这起犯罪具有性动机。他们认为凶手在前一晚以提供她想要的搭便车为幌子接走了珍妮特，随后在车内袭击并杀害了她。然后他将她的尸体抛在后来发现她的那段路边的物品中。珍妮特搭便车的地方距离 13 个月前发现莱斯利·佩洛夫被弃汽车的地方不到一英里，并且她们的尸体被发现时相距两英里。两位年轻女性都被部分脱去衣物、勒死并赤脚留在原地。尽管两起谋杀案之间有相似之处，但圣马特奥县警长办公室的一位督察
Department told the press no direct link had been established, stating, There are some circumstantial similarities and some dissimilarities. At this point, you can just about draw any conclusions you want. Nevertheless, many members of the public believed the two women shared the same killer. Investigators explored several leads in Janet's case, including a witness report of a nervous man seen near the entrance to Searsville Lake, not far from where Janet's body was found, at about 12.15am on the night of her abduction. A witness saw the man standing next to a white 1964 Pontiac Catalina and stopped to ask if he
对媒体表示，尚未建立直接联系，并表示：“存在一些情境相似之处和一些不同之处。此时此刻，你几乎可以得出你想要的任何结论。”尽管如此，许多公众成员认为两名女性拥有同一个凶手。调查人员在珍妮特的案件中探索了多条线索，包括一份证人报告，称在绑架当晚约 12 点 15 分，在珍妮特尸体被发现附近不远处的塞尔斯维尔湖入口附近看到一名神情紧张的男子。一名证人看到该男子站在一辆白色的 1964 年庞蒂克卡塔利娜旁，并停下来询问他
had any problems with his car. When he said he did not, the witness drove away. Regarded as a slim lead, this inquiry went nowhere. By the next month of April, police conceded there had been no progress in the investigation, with one officer remarking, We don't know who we're looking for. We have no motive. Located in the main quadrangle at the center of Stanford University is the Memorial Church, regarded as the campus' architectural crown jewel. In 1903, the university's co-founder, Jane Stanford, dedicated the building to the memory of her husband to Leland.
的车是否有问题。当他说没有时，证人便开车离开了。由于这是一条微不足道的线索，这项调查无果而终。到了次月 4 月，警方承认调查没有任何进展，一名警官评论道：“我们不知道我们在找谁。我们没有任何动机。”位于斯坦福大学中心主方庭内的是纪念教堂，被视为校园的建筑皇冠上的明珠。1903 年，该大学的共同创始人简·斯坦福将这座建筑奉献给她的丈夫利兰的纪念。
She had two objectives for the church, to ensure that students had an opportunity to develop their ethics as well as their studies, and to provide comfort and strength to the wider community. The Stanford's were religious, but did not follow a particular denomination, and decreed the church to be open to all. Jane Stanford was deeply committed to the church's design, stating, While my whole heart is in the university, my soul is in that church. At her instruction, inspirational messages and religious inscriptions were carved into its walls and enclosed in its frameworks. One quotation, located in the church's east
她对教堂有两个目标：确保学生有机会培养他们的伦理以及学业，并为更广泛的社区提供安慰和力量。斯坦福夫妇是有宗教信仰的，但不属于特定的教派，并下令该教堂对所有人开放。简·斯坦福深深致力于教堂的设计，并表示：“虽然我的全心都在大学里，但我的灵魂在那座教堂里。”在她的指示下，励志信息和宗教铭文被雕刻在它的墙壁上并包裹在它的框架中。教堂东翼的一处引文
transept, reads, Religion is intended as a comfort, a solace, a necessity to the soul's welfare, and whichever form of religion furnishes the greatest comfort, the greatest solace. It is the form which should be adopted, be its name, what it will. Built from buff sandstone and laid out in the shape of a cross, the ornate building has a terracotta tile roof, round turrets, low arches, and a colourful facade featuring artwork of Jesus Christ surrounded by worshipers. The interior is decorated with mosaic murals, stained glass windows, and purple velvet tapestries covering the walls. The church can seat 1,200 people and houses five organs,
写道：“宗教旨在成为一种安慰、一种慰藉、灵魂福祉的必需品，无论哪种形式的宗教提供了最大的安慰、最大的慰藉，它就是应该采用的形式，无论其名字是什么。”这座装饰华丽的建筑由淡黄色砂岩建成，呈十字形，拥有西班牙陶瓦屋顶、圆形炮楼、低矮的拱门以及色彩斑斓的立面，其上有被信徒环绕的耶稣基督的艺术作品。内部装饰有马赛克壁画、彩色玻璃窗和覆盖墙壁的紫色天鹅绒挂毯。教堂可容纳 1,200 人，并拥有五个管风琴、
rows of wooden pews, and a lectern. Students use the quiet, serene building as a place of reflection, and Catholic services are held there several times a week. Shortly after 5.30 am on Sunday, October 13, 1974, a Stanford University night watchman crossed the main quad and arrived at the memorial church to open its doors for the day. He entered the building via the west side door and walked through the nave of the church into the rear eastern transept. To the left of the altar, underneath a stained glass mosaic of a cross, he found the body of a young woman. When he phoned his supervisors to report the discovery, he remarked, Hey, we've got a stiff in here.
一排排木制长椅和一个讲台。学生们将这座安静、祥和的建筑视为反思的地方，天主教礼拜仪式每周在那里举行数次。1974 年 10 月 13 日星期日清晨 5 点 30 分后不久，斯坦福大学的一名夜间看守史蒂芬·克劳福德穿过主方庭，来到纪念教堂，为当天的开门做准备。他从西侧门进入建筑物，穿过教堂的中殿，进入后部的东翼。在圣坛左侧、十字架的彩色玻璃马赛克下方，他发现了一具年轻女性的尸体。当他打电话给上司报告这一发现时，他评论道：“嘿，我们这里有一具僵尸。”
Arliss K. Dykema was born on February 22, 1955, in the town of Linton, North Dakota. She was the youngest of three children to parents Marvin and Jean, devout Christians who raised their children to be closely connected with the Presbyterian Church. In 1963, the Dykema family relocated to the state capital of Bismarck, a small, isolated city on the eastern banks of the Missouri River, surrounded by forests and an extensive network of hiking trails. Marvin and Jean ran an automotive company named Dykema's Standard and helped found the Bismarck Reformed Church, later renamed the Bismarck Community Church, where Marvin served as an elder and Sunday school superintendent. Arliss attended Bismarck High School, where she was
阿利斯·K·戴凯玛（Arliss K. Dykema）于 1955 年 2 月 22 日出生于北达科他州林顿镇。她是父母马文（Marvin）和让（Jean）的三个孩子中的老幺，这对虔诚的基督徒将他们的孩子抚养长大，使其与长老会保持紧密的联系。1963 年，戴凯玛一家搬到了州首府俾斯麦，这是一座位于密苏里河东岸的小型、孤立的城市，周围环绕着森林和广泛的远足小径网络。马文和让经营着一家名为“戴凯玛标准”（Dykema's Standard）的汽车公司，并帮助创立了俾斯麦改革宗教堂（后来更名为俾斯麦社区教堂），马文在那里担任长老和主日学校长。阿利斯就读于俾斯麦高中，在那里她
selected for the cheerleading squad three years in a row. She was described by her coach, Marge Hill, as a bubbly and enthusiastic cheerleader, but also was self-contained girl, who was easily frightened by violence and hostility. She was a popular student and often baked cupcakes for her fellow cheerleaders and the school's basketball team. Arliss inherited her parents' religious devotion and was deeply involved with her church community, which led to a somewhat sheltered life. She had a sense of naivety and was extremely trusting due to always seeing the best in people. On weekends, Arliss taught Sunday school and worked for Young Life, a Christian youth organization dedicated to spreading the word of Jesus Christ to adolescents and helping teenagers to develop
连续三年被选入拉拉队。她的教练玛吉·希尔（Marge Hill）形容她是一个活泼热情的拉拉队员，但也是一个性格内向的女孩，很容易被暴力和敌意吓到。她是一个受欢迎的学生，经常为同伴拉拉队员和学校的篮球队烤纸杯蛋糕。阿利斯继承了父母对宗教的虔诚，深度参与了她的教会社区，这导致她过着某种程度上受到庇护的生活。她有一种天真感，并且由于总是看到人性好的一面而极其容易信任他人。周末，阿利斯教主日学，并为“年轻生命”（Young Life）工作，这是一个致力于向青少年传播耶稣基督的话语并帮助青少年发展的基督教青年组织。
their faith. She was also a member of the International Non-Prophet Sports Ministry Fellowship of Christian Athletes, or the FCA. It was through the FCA that Arliss met and fell in love with Bruce Perry, a fellow Bismarck-high student who shared her religious beliefs and athletic prowess, setting state records in track and field for the 100 and 220-yard sprints. Bruce was born and raised in Bismarck as the second of four children to his homemaker-mother Donna and dentist father, Dr Duncan Perry. His childhood was one of comfort and he grew up into a fun-loving, popular teenager who was fascinated by anthropology and different cultures. In 1973, Arliss and Bruce graduated high school. Based on his athletic performance,
他们的信仰。她还是国际非先知体育事工基督教运动员团契（FCA）的成员。正是在 FCA，阿利斯遇到了并爱上了布鲁斯·佩里（Bruce Perry），他也是一名俾斯麦高中的学生，与她有着相同的宗教信仰和出色的运动天赋，在田径 100 码和 220 码短跑中创下了州纪录。布鲁斯在俾斯麦出生并长大，是家庭主妇母亲唐娜（Donna）和牙医父亲邓肯·佩里（Duncan Perry）博士的四个孩子中的老二。他的童年生活优越，成长为一个充满乐趣、广受欢迎的青少年，对人类学和不同文化着迷。1973 年，阿利斯和布鲁斯高中毕业。基于他的运动表现，
Bruce was accepted into Stanford University and enrolled as a pre-med student majoring in human biology. Arliss remained in Bismarck, attending classes at junior college and working as a receptionist at the dental clinic owned by Bruce's father. The young couple maintained a long-distance relationship and in May of 1974, Bruce returned to Bismarck to ask for Arliss's hand in marriage. The dichomers had mixed feelings about the engagement as they weren't happy about Arliss having to move far away from family and friends to California. However, when they saw how thrilled the young couple were, they supported the marriage wholeheartedly. The wedding was held on August 17, 1974 at the Bismarck Reformed Church. Afterwards, the 19-year-old newlyweds enjoyed a one-week
布鲁斯被斯坦福大学录取，并作为一名以人类生物学为主修专业的预科生入学。阿利斯留在俾斯麦，在初级学院上课，并在布鲁斯父亲拥有的牙科诊所担任接待员。这对年轻夫妇保持着异地恋关系，1974 年 5 月，布鲁斯回到俾斯麦请求迎娶阿利斯。戴凯玛夫妇对这桩订婚心情复杂，因为他们对阿利斯不得不搬到远在加利福尼亚的远离家人和朋友的地方感到不快。然而，当他们看到这对年轻夫妇是多么兴奋时，他们全心全意地支持这桩婚姻。婚礼于 1974 年 8 月 17 日在俾斯麦改革宗教堂举行。此后，这对 19 岁的新婚夫妇享受了一个星期的
honeymoon in a rustic log cabin owned by the dichomers and in September, Arliss embarked on the 1600-mile journey to Stanford with Bruce. They moved into Quillen Hall in Stanford's Escondido Village, an apartment block designated to house married couples, and Bruce began his sophomore year. It was the first time Arliss had ever been away from home and she missed her support network. While Bruce was busy studying and working part-time, Arliss struggled to adjust to her new life. She was used to living in a small, close-knit community and found Stanford lonely and isolating. She wrote a letter home which read, Friends are hard to find here. Many times I've been tempted to go knock on doors asking if anyone
蜜月，地点是戴凯玛夫妇拥有的一间乡村原木小屋；9 月，阿利斯与布鲁斯踏上了前往斯坦福的 1600 英里旅程。他们搬进了斯坦福埃斯昆迪多村（Escondido Village）的奎伦大厅（Quillen Hall），这是一栋专为已婚夫妇提供住所的公寓楼，布鲁斯开始了他人生的第二年大学生活。这是阿利斯第一次离家，她非常想念她的支持网络。当布鲁斯忙于学习和兼职工作时，阿利斯很难适应她的新生活。她习惯于生活在一个小型、紧密联系的社区中，并发现斯坦福既孤独又孤立。她写了一封家书，上面写道：“这里很难交到朋友。很多次我都忍不住去敲门，问是否有人
needs a friend. But I guess we just have to appreciate each other and trust the Lord for new friends too. Arliss accepted a job as a receptionist at a Palo Alto law firm and slowly began to adapt, becoming a member of the Stanford Church and spending time with Bruce whenever their schedules allowed. When her husband was busy, Arliss took long walks or jogs around the University campus and occasionally visited the Memorial Church to pray. Oftentimes she would head out alone at night but stopped after Bruce warned her it wasn't safe to do so. On the evening of Saturday, October 12, 1974, Arliss busied herself around the apartment while Bruce studied. At around 11.30pm, Bruce agreed to accompany Arliss to post some letters addressed
需要一个朋友。但我想我们只需要彼此珍惜，并相信主也会给我们带来新朋友。”阿利斯在帕洛阿尔托的一家律师事务所找到了一份接待员的工作，并慢慢开始适应，成为了斯坦福教堂的成员，并在时间允许的情况下陪伴布鲁斯。当她的丈夫忙碌时，阿利斯会在大学校园周围长时间散步或慢跑，并偶尔参观纪念教堂祈祷。她经常在夜间独自一人外出，但在布鲁斯警告她这样做不安全后停了下来。在 1974 年 10 月 12 日星期六的晚上，阿利斯在公寓里忙碌，而布鲁斯则在学习。大约晚上 11 点 30 分，布鲁斯同意陪阿利斯去寄一些信件，这些信件是写给
to her family and friends in Bismarck as it would afford the couple some time together and he didn't want her going out alone at night. It was Columbus Day, a national holiday marking the anniversary of Christopher Columbus' arrival to America and the University was a hive of activity with rowdy people milling about and music playing loudly from student residences. As Arliss and Bruce walked across campus, they got into a minor argument over their car tyre which had been losing pressure lately and disagreed over who was responsible for pumping it up. By the time they had posted the letters, it was approximately 11.50pm. Still upset by their argument, Arliss told Bruce she wanted to visit the Memorial Church alone to
她在俾斯麦的家人和朋友的，因为这可以让这对夫妇有一些在一起的时间，而且他不想让她独自在晚上外出。那天是哥伦布日，是一个纪念克里斯托弗·哥伦布抵达美洲周年的全国假日，大学里人头攒动，喧闹的人群四处游荡，学生宿舍里播放着高亢的音乐。当阿利斯和布鲁斯走过校园时，他们为他们的汽车轮胎发生了一点争吵，该轮胎最近一直在漏气，并且在谁负责给它充气的问题上意见不一致。等他们寄完信时，大约已经是晚上 11 点 50 分了。仍然对他们的争吵感到沮丧，阿利斯告诉布鲁斯她想独自去纪念教堂
pray. This was not unusual as they both visited the church when they needed to reflect and ask for guidance. The building was open until midnight and located only half a mile from the Perry's apartment. Back at the apartment, Bruce awaited Arliss's return but by 12.30am there was no sign of her. He returned to the church but it was now closed for the night and all the doors were locked. He fruitlessly searched the campus before going home again, finding their apartment empty. At 3am, he reported Arliss missing, expressing his concern as he knew she had no friends in town and there was nowhere else she could have gone. He suggested that she might have accidentally fallen asleep inside the church and been locked in by mistake so some officers were dispatched
祈祷。这并不罕见，因为他们俩在需要反思和寻求指导时都会参观教堂。教堂开放至午夜，距离佩里夫妇的公寓只有半英里。回到公寓后，布鲁斯等待阿利斯回来，但到了 12 点 30 分，依然没有她的踪影。他回到教堂，但此时教堂已经关门过夜，所有的门都锁上了。他在校园里毫无结果地搜寻了一番，然后又回到了家，发现他们的公寓空无一人。凌晨 3 点，他报告阿利斯失踪，并表达了他的担忧，因为他知道她在城里没有朋友，而且没有其他地方可去。他建议她可能不小心在教堂里睡着了，被错误地锁在里面，因此一些警官被派去
to check the building. As it was still securely locked, they were only able to survey its exterior but noticed nothing suspicious. The situation appeared to be a relatively benign domestic dispute and the officers presumed Arliss would reappear once she had calmed down. Approximately two and a half hours later, Stanford University night watchman Stephen Crawford came across Arliss's body in the memorial church. She was on her back with her arms folded across her chest and her legs spread. Her head was facing the altar and her body was partially underneath the first pew with a kneeling pillow nearby. She was still wearing her dark brown jacket though her tan sweater had been pushed up to expose her chest. Her underwear
检查建筑物。由于它仍然牢牢锁着，他们只能勘察其外观，但没有发现任何可疑之处。这种情况似乎是一个相对温和的家庭纠纷，警官们推测阿利斯冷静下来后就会重新出现。大约两个半小时后，斯坦福大学夜间看守史蒂芬·克劳福德在纪念教堂里发现了阿利斯的尸体。她仰面躺着，双臂交叉在胸前，双腿张开。她的头部面向圣坛，身体部分位于第一排长椅下方，附近放着一个跪垫。她仍然穿着深棕色夹克，但浅棕色毛衣被推了上去，露出了胸部。她的内衣
and blue jeans had been removed with the pants draped over her lower body and the legs facing towards her head. Markings on her neck were consistent with an attempted strangulation and her glasses were missing. Given they were a valueless item, it was speculated her killer had taken them as a morbid trophy. Arliss had been sexually assaulted using two 36 inch long altar candles, one of which was still partially inserted inside her body. The other had been placed between her breasts. There was no sign of a struggle indicating Arliss had been caught off guard by her killer. Her time of death was estimated to have been around midnight, shortly after she entered the church. The assault with the candles was believed to have
和蓝色牛仔裤已被脱下，裤子披在她的下半身上，裤腿朝向她的头部。她脖子上的痕迹与试图勒死的情况相符，她的眼镜不见了。鉴于它们是没有价值的物品，人们推测她的凶手将它们作为可怕的战利品拿走了。阿利斯遭到性侵犯，使用的是两支 36 英寸长的圣坛蜡烛，其中一支仍然部分插入她的体内。另一支则被放在她的乳房之间。没有打斗的迹象，这表明阿利斯被凶手打了个措手不及。据估计，她的死亡时间在午夜左右，就在她进入教堂后不久。用蜡烛进行袭击被认为发生于
occurred afterwards. The pointed end of an ice pick was still embedded in an open head wound just above her left ear, though the weapon's handle had snapped off. As it was not bound at the crime scene, it was presumed the killer had taken it away. Although a small bone in Arliss's neck had been broken, it was determined that the ice pick injury had caused her death. A partial palm print of unknown origin was also found on one of the altar candles, a significant find before the introduction of DNA analysis, although it was indistinct. The police arrived at the Perry's apartment just after dawn. Bruce answered the door, wearing a blood-covered shirt. He explained he had used his clothing to stop a nosebleed,
在那之后。一把冰镐的尖端仍然嵌在她左耳上方的一个开着伤口中，尽管武器的手柄已经折断。由于在犯罪现场没有找到手柄，人们推测凶手把它拿走了。尽管阿利斯脖子上的一根小骨头已经断裂，但经确定是冰镐伤导致了她的死亡。在其中一支圣坛蜡烛上还发现了一个来源不明的部分掌纹，在 DNA 分析引入之前这是一个重要的发现，尽管它很不清晰。警方在破晓刚过就来到了佩里夫妇的公寓。布鲁斯打开了门，穿着一件沾满血迹的衬衫。他解释说他用自己的衣服来止鼻血，
which he was prone to getting during times of high anxiety. He wasn't immediately informed of Arliss's murder, but was asked to attend the police station to file a missing person report. Bruce was questioned for two hours, with investigators presenting him with different scenarios to see how he would react. He was staunchly defensive when it was suggested that he had lashed out at Arliss upon discovering she was having an affair or had fallen pregnant. Bruce voluntarily provided his fingerprints and agreed to undergo a polygraph test, all the while repeatedly asking, where's my wife? When he passed the polygraph, the police finally informed him that Arliss had been killed.
他在极度焦虑的时候很容易流鼻血。他没有立即被告知阿利斯的谋杀案，但被要求去警察局提交失踪人口报告。布鲁斯被讯问了两个小时，调查人员向他提出了不同的假设情景，以观察他的反应。当有人暗示他在发现阿利斯有外遇或怀孕后对她大打出手时，他进行了坚决的辩护。布鲁斯自愿提供了他的指纹并同意接受测谎测试，同时一再询问：“我的妻子在哪里？”当他通过了测谎测试后，警方终于通知他阿利斯已经被杀害了。
Sunday mass at the memorial church went ahead at 11 o'clock the following morning. The congregation, which included journalists and grieving students, were seated on folding chairs placed on the front lawn to preserve the crime scene inside. They were told of Arliss's murder and asked to join in a silent prayer. According to reports, Dean of the Stanford Chapel, Reverend Robert Hamilton Kelly, had seen Arliss's body and expressed his belief that its treatment appeared symbolic as though the murder had been part of a satanic ritual. He told the congregation that he refused to let evil triumph and church services would continue as normal. That evening,
第二天上午 11 点，纪念教堂的主日弥撒照常进行。会众，包括记者和悲伤的学生，坐在放置在前草坪上的折叠椅上，以保护内部的犯罪现场。他们被告知了阿利斯的谋杀案，并被要求参与默哀。据报道，斯坦福教堂院长罗伯特·汉密尔顿·凯利（Robert Hamilton Kelly）牧师看到了阿利斯的尸体，并表示他相信其遭遇看起来具有象征意义，仿佛谋杀是某种邪教仪式的一部分。他告诉会众，他拒绝让邪恶获胜，教堂服务将照常进行。那天晚上，
a Catholic priest blessed the building to cleanse it of malevolent forces. The FBI constructed a profile of Arliss's killer, describing him as a loner with a possible military background, aged between 17 and 22, who kept a detailed diary and collected his victims' possessions as trophies. When asked what he remembered about the night of Sunday, October 13, Bruce Perry couldn't recall anyone watching or following him or Arliss when they went their separate ways in the main quad. Two people who were in the memorial church when Arliss Perry entered said she had walked to the front pews on the left-hand side of the altar, then knelt down to pray. She was still
一位天主教神父祝福了这座建筑，以驱除恶意力量。联邦调查局（FBI）构建了阿利斯凶手的心理画像，将其描述为一个有潜在军方背景、年龄在 17 到 22 岁之间、写详细日记并收集受害者财物作为战利品的独行侠。当被问及对 10 月 13 日星期日晚上的事有什么记忆时，布鲁斯·佩里说他不记得当他和阿利斯在主方庭分道扬镳时，有任何人看着或跟着他们。两名在阿利斯·佩里进入纪念教堂时在场的人说，她走到了圣坛左侧的前排长椅旁，然后跪下祈祷。她仍然
deep in prayer when they left at midnight. A passerby who had been outside reported seeing a Caucasian man with sandy-colored hair parted to the left and to the church around this time. He was approximately 25 years old, had a medium build, and was casually dressed in a royal blue short-sleeved shirt. Night watchman Stephen Crawford said he had been running late to lock up the church, arriving at ten minutes past midnight. He entered the rear of the building and couldn't see anyone inside, but just in case he yelled out, we're closing for the night, the church is being locked. If anyone is here, you'll have to leave. When nobody responded, he closed and locked the doors.
深陷祈祷中，直到他们在午夜离开。一名在外面呆过的路人报告说，大约在这个时候，看到一名白人男子，留着中分到左侧的沙金色头发，走向教堂。他大约 25 岁，身材中等，穿着一件休闲的皇家蓝色短袖衬衫。夜间看守史蒂芬·克劳福德说他锁教堂的时间晚了，于午夜过后的十分钟到达。他从建筑物的后部进入，里面看不到任何人，但他还是大声喊道：“我们要关门过夜了，教堂要上锁了。如果有人在这里，你必须离开。”当没有人回应时，他关上并锁上了门。
Due to the extent of Arliss's injuries, it seemed unlikely that her assault occurred in the ten-minute window between when the other churchgoers left and the building was secured. That was plausible that when Stephen Crawford called out to see if anyone was still inside, the perpetrator may have already confronted Arliss and forced her silence. This theory aligned with a statement given by another witness. Sometime between 12.15 and 12.30 a.m., a man passing the church thought he heard a noise coming from inside the building towards the choir loft. He paused to listen, but heard nothing further, so assumed he'd imagined it and kept walking.
鉴于阿利斯伤势的严重程度，她的袭击似乎不太可能发生在其他教堂信徒离开和建筑物被安保这之间的十分分钟窗口期内。一种合理的可能性是，当史蒂芬·克劳福德大声询问是否有人还在里面时，凶手可能已经与阿利斯对峙并迫使她保持沉默。这个理论与另一名证人提供的陈述相吻合。在 12 点 15 分到 12 点 30 分之间的某个时候，一名路过教堂的男子认为他听到里面传出了朝着唱诗班阁楼方向的声音。他停下来听了一下，但没有听到进一步的声音，所以以为是自己想象出来的，然后继续往前走。
When Stephen Crawford returned to the church at around 5.30 a.m. to open it up again, he approached the west side door and noticed it was partially open. The lock appeared to have been broken open from the inside and he suspected a robbery had taken place. After entering cautiously, he discovered Arliss's body, though no one else was inside. Investigators were also informed there was a window in one of the church restrooms that didn't lock and might have provided a covert access point for Arliss's killer. It was possible they entered via the unlocked window and then broke out through the west side door. Crawford claimed that during his shift he entered the church at 2.00 a.m. to conduct a routine check.
当史蒂芬·克劳福德大约在凌晨 5 点 30 分返回教堂重新开门时，他走近西侧门，发现它半开着。锁似乎是从内部被撬开的，他怀疑发生了一起抢劫。在谨慎进入后，他发现了阿利斯的尸体，但里面没有其他人。调查人员还获悉，教堂洗手间里有一扇窗户没有上锁，可能为阿利斯的凶手提供了一个隐蔽的进入点。他们有可能通过未上锁的窗户进入，然后从西侧门砸门而出。克劳福德声称他在值班期间于凌晨 2 点进入教堂进行例行检查。
At that time, the west side door was locked and he noted nothing of concern inside. As Arliss was killed shortly after midnight, this assertion didn't fit with the police timeline, as Crawford would have encountered her killer or her body if he entered the church at 2.00 a.m. It was believed that Crawford did not conduct his 2.00 a.m. check, but claimed he did, so to cover up his own negligence in failing to carry out his duties. Due to his ability to access the building, Stephen Crawford was considered a suspect, but was ruled out after passing a polygraph test and when it was determined that his palm print didn't match the one on the altar candle found with Arliss's body.
当时，西侧门是锁着的，他没有注意到里面有任何令人担忧的事情。由于阿利斯在午夜后不久被杀，这一说法与警方的事件时间线不符，因为如果克劳福德在凌晨 2 点进入教堂，他本会遇到她的凶手或她的尸体。人们认为克劳福德并没有进行凌晨 2 点的检查，但声称自己做了，以此来掩盖他未能履行职责的自身疏忽。由于他有进入建筑物的能力，史蒂芬·克劳福德被视为嫌疑人，但在通过测谎测试并且确定他的掌纹与在阿利斯尸体旁发现的圣坛蜡烛上的掌纹不匹配后，他被排除了嫌疑。
Robert Hammett and Kelly, dean of the Stanford Chapel, raised suspicions as he too had access to the building at all times, but he also passed a polygraph and his palm print wasn't a match. In total, more than 100 palm prints were lifted from various surfaces throughout the church, but none matched the one on the candle. Seven people were identified as having visited the memorial church on the night Arliss was killed, including Arliss herself. Each person of interest was identified and subsequently cleared, except for the sandy-haired man in the royal blue shirt. The Arliss Perry case marked the third unsolved murder of a young woman on or near Stanford
斯坦福教堂院长罗伯特·哈梅特和凯利引起了人们的怀疑，因为他同样可以随时进入该建筑，但他也通过了测谎测试，并且他的掌纹也不匹配。总共从教堂各处的表面提取了 100 多个掌纹，但没有一个与蜡烛上的掌纹相匹配。七人被确定在阿利斯遇害当晚访问过纪念教堂，其中包括阿利斯本人。每个受关注的人都被确定并随后被清白，除了那个穿着皇家蓝色衬衫的沙发男子。阿利斯·佩里案标志着不到两年内在斯坦福大学或附近发生的第三起年轻女性未破谋杀案。
University in less than two years. A $10,000 reward resulted in a few tip-offs from the public, but none offered any useful leads. On Tuesday, October 15, a memorial service was held for Arliss inside the memorial church, where the crime scene was still cordoned off with rope. Reverend Hammett and Kelly told the 180 people in attendance, Arliss Perry died in this church, the victim of violence and perversion. We are in a conflict with evil, there is a battle going on, but only love can win that battle. If it were to turn us from love to hate, from love to bitterness, then evil would have triumphed. The Reverend described how Arliss was now a part of their place of worship, stating,
10,000 美元的悬赏金引来了一些公众的线索，但没有一条提供有用的线索。10 月 14 日星期二，在纪念教堂内为阿利斯举行了一场追悼会，犯罪现场周围仍然拉着警戒线。哈梅特和凯利牧师对在场的 180 人说：“阿利斯·佩里在这座教堂里去世，是暴力和变态的受害者。我们正与邪恶发生冲突，一场战斗正在进行，但只有爱才能赢得这场战斗。如果它让我们从爱走向恨，从爱走向怨恨，那么邪恶就战胜了。”牧师描述了阿利斯现在如何成为他们礼拜场所的一部分，并说道：
she fills the church with her glorious presence, before detailing her devotion to Christ and how she and her husband planned to embark on missionary work upon Bruce's graduation from Stanford. From his seat in the front pew, Bruce Perry maintained his composure, but eventually broke down when music by the German composer Bach was played on one of the church organs. He managed to join in singing the final hymn before the Reverend told the mourners not to be overcome with sorrow, bitterness or a vengeful spirit. Upon the conclusion of the service, Bruce hastily left the church through a rear door. Three days later, Arliss's funeral was held in her hometown at the Bismarck Reformed Church,
她带着神圣庄严的气息充满整座教堂，接着她细述了自己对基督的虔诚，以及她和丈夫计划在布鲁斯从斯坦福毕业后开始从事宣教工作。布鲁斯·佩里坐在前排长椅上保持着镇定，但当教堂的一台管风琴奏起德国作曲家巴赫的音乐时，他终于崩溃了。他设法加入唱完最后一首赞美诗，随后牧师告诫哀悼者不要被悲伤、痛苦或复仇的情绪压倒。仪式结束后，布鲁斯从后门匆忙离开了教堂。三天后，阿莉丝的葬礼在她家乡的俾斯麦归正教堂举行，
where she and Bruce were wed just two months earlier. For many of her family, friends and community, the celebration had been the last time they saw her alive. Reverend Don de Cock officiated, reading passages from Arliss's personal Bible that she had underlined and marked with the word nice, including the phrases, the Lord is my shepherd, the Lord is my light and my salvation, whom shall I fear? Arliss's close friend Peggy, who had been a bridesmaid at her wedding, told the press. Arliss was a good friend. I loved her a lot. She was serious and quiet, but she cared a lot about people, and what mattered to her most was her Lord and Bruce. I have watched her grow.
就在两个月前，她和布鲁斯才在那里结为连理。对她的许多家人、朋友和社区成员来说，那场庆典是他们最后一次见到活着的她。唐·德·考克牧师主持了葬礼，并诵读了阿莉丝个人圣经中她画过线并标有“美好”字样的段落，其中包括“耶和华是我的牧者”、“耶和华是我的亮光，是我的拯救，我还怕谁呢？”等短语。阿莉丝的密友佩姬曾在她的婚礼上担任伴娘，她对媒体说：阿莉丝是个好朋友。我非常爱她。她严肃而安静，但她非常关心别人，对她最重要的是她的主和布鲁斯。我看着她长大，
I've seen how the Lord has worked in her life, and I know she's with him. A temporary grave marker was placed on Arliss's burial plot, while her family awaited construction of a permanent tombstone. Two weeks after her funeral, the grave marker was stolen. This prompted theories that the killer was a Bismarck resident who'd followed Arliss to California with the intention of killing her, and had then returned to take the grave marker as another morbid trophy. The idea that Arliss knew her killer wasn't without merit, with some suspecting he was a scorned ex-boyfriend or an obsessed stalker. The day before Arliss's murder, a colleague witnessed her in the waiting room of their law office, having a serious and intense
我看到主在她生命中行了奇事，我知道她与主同在。阿莉丝的墓地上安放了一个临时墓碑，而她的家人则在等待永久墓碑的建造。葬礼两周后，这个墓碑被偷了。这引发了一些推测，认为凶手是俾斯麦当地人，他尾随阿莉丝来到加利福尼亚，企图将她杀害，然后又返回偷走墓碑作为另一个病态的战利品。阿莉丝认识凶手这种说法并非毫无根据，一些人怀疑凶手是一个受挫的前男友或一个痴迷的跟踪狂。在阿莉丝被谋杀的前一天，一位同事目睹她在律所的候诊室里，
conversation with a man in his early 20s. The co-worker originally thought it was Arliss's husband, but later saw Bruce Perry at a memorial service, and realized he was not the man from the waiting room. Arliss and the unknown man spoke for about 15 minutes, and when she returned to work, she seemed noticeably sad, but didn't mention the encounter to anyone. Her visitor was described as approximately five foot ten inches tall, with an athletic build, broad shoulders, and short curly blonde hair. This description bore similarities to the seventh unidentified person in the vicinity of the memorial church when Arliss was inside praying, the man in the royal blue shirt. Bruce confirmed he had never stopped by at Arliss's workplace, as she had specifically
和一个20岁出头的男子进行严肃而激烈的交谈。这位同事最初以为那是阿莉丝的丈夫，但后来在追悼会上看到了布鲁斯·佩里，才意识到他并非候诊室里的那个男人。阿莉丝和这个陌生男子交谈了大约15分钟，当她回到工作岗位时，显得明显有些难过，但没有向任何人提及这次偶遇。据描述，她的访客身高约五英尺十英寸，身材健硕，宽肩膀，留着短卷金发。这个描述与阿莉丝在里面祈祷时纪念教堂附近的第七个未识别身份的人（那个穿宝蓝色衬衫的男子）有相似之处。布鲁斯证实他从未去过阿莉丝的工作场所，因为她曾明确
asked him not to visit until she had settled in to her new job. She hadn't mentioned any strange encounters, though Bruce was certain that she would likely keep such an incident to herself to avoid upsetting him. He was unable to identify the man Arliss was speaking with. In their book Bloody Ivy, 13 Unsolved Campus Murders, authors Chris and Harry Babonich speculated that Arliss's killer may not have planned to commit murder that night, due to the opportunistic nature of her slaying and the fact that he left behind vital evidence. They proposed that the perpetrator might have been a vagrant who was using the church as a refuge, or a vandal who planned to desecrate the Holy Sanctuary.
要求他直到安顿好新工作之前不要来访。她没有提及任何奇怪的遭遇，不过布鲁斯确信，为了避免让他心烦，她很可能会将此类事件深埋心底。他无法认出与阿莉丝交谈的那个男人。克里斯和哈里·巴博尼奇在他们的书《血腥常春藤：13起未破的校园谋杀案》中推测，由于阿莉丝遇害的随机性以及凶手留下了关键证据，凶手当晚可能并非蓄意谋杀。他们提出，作案者可能是一个把教堂当避难所的流浪汉，或者是计划亵渎圣所的破坏者。
Perhaps he was behaving suspiciously and Arliss confronted him. Perhaps he was attracted to her and an argument began. In any case, the confrontation had turned physical before Stephen Crawford entered to close the church. Hearing Crawford approach, the attacker subdued Arliss either by holding his hand over her mouth or by threatening her with the ice pick, and hid until Crawford left the church. Dean of the Stanford Chapel, Reverend Robert Hamilton Kelly, had since denied making statements that Arliss's murder resembled a satanic ritual, explaining that her injuries and the crime scene didn't have the elements one would typically expect from such a slaughter.
也许他行为诡异，阿莉丝质问了他；也许他被她吸引，两人发生了争执。无论如何，在斯蒂芬·克劳福德进入教堂锁门之前，对峙已经升级为肢体冲突。听到克劳福德走近，袭击者或是用手捂住阿莉丝的嘴，或是用冰锥威胁她，将其制服，并躲藏起来直到克劳福德离开教堂。斯坦福礼拜堂院长罗伯特·汉密尔顿·凯利牧师此后否认曾发表过阿莉丝的谋杀类似撒旦仪式的言论，他解释说她的伤势和犯罪现场并不具备人们通常会从这种屠杀中预期的元素。
Nevertheless, the theory had stuck, and at one point, Sheriff Lieutenant Robert Barthou told the media that police were exploring all possibilities, including that the murder was carried out for this purpose. Some reports claimed her body was posed with her knees bent and ankles drawn together, creating the points of a pentagram. Others said her genes had been arranged in a manner that resembled the symbol of the world's largest secret society, the Freemasons. Investigators dismissed these assertions by clarifying that Arliss's legs were left straight, not formed into a diamond shape like many incorrectly believed. In Bismarck, word spread that during the year Bruce was living at Stanford on his own,
尽管如此，这种理论还是流传开来，有一次，警长中尉罗伯特·巴图告诉媒体，警方正在探索所有可能性，包括谋杀是为达到此目的而实施的。一些报道称，她的尸体被摆成双膝弯曲、脚踝并拢的姿势，形成了五角星的尖角。另一些人则称她的基因（注：原文genis为笔误，应指牛仔裤jeans）以类似于世界最大秘密组织共济会标志的方式排列。调查人员澄清说，阿莉丝的腿是直的，并没有像许多人错误认为的那样摆成菱形，从而驳斥了这些说法。在俾斯麦，有传言称，在布鲁斯独自住在斯坦福的那一年里，
Arliss and a friend had travelled to the neighbouring town of Mandan, North Dakota. The pair aimed to convert members of a local satanic cult to Christianity as part of their work with the Young Life Organization. The alleged cult, the Process Church of the Final Judgement, was a religious group associated with Scientology and Satanism, and its members were rumoured to carry out rituals in parks and caves throughout Bismarck. One local recalled people visiting the town wearing priest robes with red collars and necklaces with upside-down crosses. Detectives ruled out this theory after it couldn't be confirmed that Arliss had ever visited the Process Church group. They publicly denounced the satanic ritual angle
阿莉丝曾和一个朋友前往北达科他州邻近的曼丹镇。作为他们与“年轻生命组织”工作的一部分，两人旨在将当地一个撒旦邪教的成员转化为基督教徒。这个所谓的邪教“审判日进程教会”是一个与科学教和撒旦主义相关的宗教团体，据传其成员在俾斯麦各地的公园和洞穴中进行仪式。当地的一位居民回忆说，有人穿着带红领的牧师长袍、戴着倒十字架项链访问该镇。在无法确认阿莉丝是否去过“进程教会”组织后，侦探们排除了这种理论。他们公开谴责了撒旦仪式的角度，
with a spokesperson telling the press. It's a typical, if there is such a thing, sexual psychopathic slaying that has no cult-like overtones. It just happened to occur in a church. Arliss Perry's murder bore similarities to the unsolved murders of Leslie Perlov and Janet Taylor, as all three women were targeted in Stanford by a sexual psychopath. Furthermore, witnesses had described seeing a blonde-haired man at both Leslie and Arliss' crime scenes shortly before their murders. Yet, there were also notable differences between the attacks. Arliss was the only victim in which the killer employed the use of a weapon, whereas Leslie and Janet had been strangled with their own clothing or the perpetrator's hands. Additionally, Leslie and Janet were
一位发言人对媒体说：这是一起典型的（如果真有这种说法的话）性心理变态谋杀，没有任何邪教色彩。它只是碰巧发生在教堂里。阿莉丝·佩里的谋杀案与莱斯利·佩洛夫和珍妮特·泰勒未破的谋杀案有相似之处，因为这三名女性都在斯坦福被性心理变态者盯上。此外，目击者曾描述在莱斯利和阿莉丝的犯罪现场附近都看到了一个金发男子，就在她们遇害前不久。然而，这些袭击之间也有明显的不同。阿莉丝是唯一一个凶手使用了武器的受害者，而莱斯利和珍妮特则是被她们自己的衣服或凶手的手勒死的。此外，莱斯利和珍妮特被
considered low-risk attacks as both were confronted in isolated areas with few people about. Arliss' attack was the opposite. It was incredibly high risk, given the amount of foot traffic around the main quad on the public holiday, including a watchman whose role was to intermittently check the memorial church throughout the night. Despite this, many Stanford residents were unable to shake the feeling that a serial killer was active in the area. In the early hours of August 16, 1975, 10 months after Arliss Perry's murder, Utah Highway Patrol officer Bob Haywood was scouting the Salt Lake City community of Granger when he spotted a distinct, green-colored 1968 Volkswagen Beetle cruising down a residential
认为是低风险袭击，因为两人都是在鲜有人迹的偏僻地区遭到对抗。阿莉丝遭遇的袭击则恰恰相反。考虑到国定假日期间主方庭周围的人流量，其中包括一名职责是在夜间不定期检查纪念教堂的守夜人，这次袭击的风险高得难以置信。尽管如此，许多斯坦福居民还是无法摆动连环杀手在该地区活动的阴影。1975年8月16日清晨，即阿莉丝·佩里遇害10个月后，犹他州公路巡警鲍勃·海伍德在盐湖城格兰杰社区巡逻时，发现了一辆特征鲜明的绿色1968年大众甲壳虫汽车在居民区
street with its lights off. Officer Haywood recognized the driver and ordered him to stop, but he fled the area at high speed. After a short chase, the car was brought to a halt, and a search of the vehicle uncovered a ski mask, a second mask fashioned from pantyhose, a crowbar, handcuffs, trash bags, a coil of rope, an ice pick, and other items assumed to be burglary tools. The driver, 28-year-old Ted Bundy, was a suspect in a long list of unsolved homicides of women and young girls that had taken place across several states throughout the preceding years. Bundy, one of America's most infamous and prolific sexual sadist serial killers, confessed to 30 homicides, though many believe the true number of his victims was higher.
街道上行驶，且没有开灯。海伍德警官认出了司机并命令他停车，但他高速逃离了现场。经过短暂的追逐，汽车被截停，对该车的搜查发现了一副滑雪面罩、第二个用连裤袜做成的面罩、一根撬棍、手铐、垃圾袋、一卷绳子、一把冰锥以及其他被认为是作案工具的物品。司机是28岁的特德·邦迪，他是过去几年中在几个州发生的针对女性和年轻女孩的一长串未破凶杀案的嫌疑人。邦迪是美国最声名狼藉、最多产的性虐待连环杀手之一，他承认了30起谋杀，尽管许多人认为他真正的受害者人数更多。
Investigators for the unsolved murders of Leslie Perlov, Janet Taylor, and Arliss Perry suspected Bundy may have been responsible for those deaths as he had studied at Stanford University in the late 60s and was familiar with the area. Several of his crimes were committed on college campuses and he had visited California's Bay Area on multiple occasions between 1973 and 74, the time of the Stanford murders. Bundy was interviewed in relation to Arliss Perry's murder, but had an airtight alibi in the form of a credit card statement, proving he was filling up his Volkswagen at a gas station out of town at the time. He was also questioned about Leslie Perlov and Janet Taylor, but was ultimately ruled out as a suspect in those crimes too.
莱斯利·佩洛夫、珍妮特·泰勒和阿莉丝·佩里未破谋杀案的调查人员怀疑邦迪可能对这些死亡负有责任，因为他在60年代末曾在斯坦福大学学习，对该地区很熟悉。他的几起罪行都是在大学校园里犯下的，并且在1973年至1974年斯坦福谋杀案发生期间，他曾多次访问加州的湾区。警方就阿莉丝·佩里的谋杀案对邦迪进行了讯问，但他拥有万无一失的不在场证明——一张信用卡消费记录，证明他在案发时正在镇外的一家加油站给他的甲壳虫汽车加油。他还被讯问了关于莱斯利·佩洛夫和珍妮特·泰勒的情况，但最终也被排除在这几起案件的嫌疑人之外。
Four years after Arliss's murder in 1978, police in her home state of North Dakota received a letter from Attica Correctional Facility in New York. According to the letter, the process church of the final judgment hired a hitman to kill Arliss Perry after she had tried to convert them to Christianity. The author of the letter was identified as 24-year-old David Berkowitz, also known as Son of Sam. He was serving six life sentences for the murders of six women in New York between 1976 and 77. On October 23, 1979, Berkowitz sent a policeman from North Dakota a book about Satanism in which he had written, Arliss Perry, hunted, stalked and slain, followed to California, Stanford University. Two sergeants from the Santa Clara County Sheriff's Department
在阿莉丝于1978年遇害四年后，她家乡北达科他州的警方收到了一封来自纽约阿提卡惩教设施的信。信中称，“审判日进程教会”雇用了名杀手来杀害阿莉丝·佩里，此前她曾试图让他们皈依基督教。这封信的作者被确认是24岁的大卫·伯克owitz，也被称为“山姆之子”。他在1976年至1977年期间因在纽约谋杀六名女性而被判处六个终身监禁。1979年10月23日，伯克沃茨给北达科他州的一名警察寄去了一本关于撒旦主义的书，他在上面写道：阿莉丝·佩里，被搜寻、跟踪并杀害，一直追到加利福尼亚斯坦福大学。圣克拉拉县治安官办公室的两名中士
traveled to New York to interview Berkowitz. He denied any involvement with Arliss's murder, explaining that the only information he had about the crime came from newspaper articles that had been sent to him. When asked if he had spoken to the person who had murdered Arliss, Berkowitz became visibly nervous and avoided answering the question. After speaking with the police for 30 minutes, he expressed concerns that other inmates would think he was working as an informant and terminated the interview. The sergeants concluded Berkowitz had nothing of value to offer their investigation and disregarded his claims. Other notorious serial killers were investigated as possible suspects in the Stanford murders, including co-ed killer Ed Kemper, who was active
前往纽约讯问伯克沃茨。他否认与阿莉丝的谋杀有任何牵连，并解释说他关于这起犯罪的唯一信息来自寄给他的报纸文章。当被问及他是否与谋杀阿莉丝的人交谈过时，伯克沃茨显得明显紧张并避而不答。在与警方交谈了30分钟后，他表达了对其他同监犯人会认为他是线人的担忧，并终止了采访。两位中士断定伯克沃茨没有提供任何有价值的调查线索，并驳回了他的说法。其他声名狼藉的连环杀手也被作为斯坦福谋杀案的可能嫌疑人进行了调查，包括“校园杀手”埃德·肯珀，他在距离斯坦福以南40英里的圣克鲁斯地区活跃，直到1973年4月自首。肯珀的作案手法
in the Santa Cruz region, 40 miles south of Stanford, up until his surrender in April 1973. Kemper's murder-sopper and I involved picking up hitchhiking female college students and taking them to isolated areas where he would kill them, sometimes via strangulation. Although the date of his arrest ruled him out for Janet and Arliss's murders, he was free at the time Leslie was killed. Two of his victims, 18-year-olds Mary Pash and Anita LaCassa, killed in May 1972, had accepted a ride from Kemper under the pretext of being taken to Stanford University. Kemper, who was infamously forthright and meticulous when speaking of his crimes to authorities after his capture, did not confess to killing Leslie.
涉及挑选搭便车的女大学生并将她们带到偏僻地区将其杀害，有时通过勒死。尽管他被捕的日期排除了他作案珍妮特和阿莉丝谋杀案的可能性，但在莱斯利被杀时他是自由的。他的两名受害者——18岁的玛丽·帕什和安妮塔·拉卡萨于1972年5月被杀，她们在被带到斯坦福大学的幌子下接受了肯珀的搭车。肯珀在被捕后向当局谈及自己的罪行时出名地坦率和一丝不苟，但他并未承认杀害了莱斯利。
In 1987, 13 years after Arliss's murder, a controversial book by investigative reporter Maury Terry titled The Ultimate Evil put the case back under the spotlight. Terry explored multiple theories and criticized investigators for not further exploring the possible link between Arliss and the process church. He proposed that she had been followed from Bismarck to California by a church member, and he was the man arguing with her at her workplace the day before her death. Terry honed in on son of Sam killer David Berkowitz as likely knowing pertinent information relating to the crime. According to Terry, on the night of her murder, Arliss may have intentionally picked a fight with Bruce as it gave her an excuse to request
1987年，在阿莉丝遇害13年后，调查记者莫里·特里的一本充满争议的书《终极邪恶》将此案重新推向了聚光灯下。特里探讨了多种理论，并批评调查人员没有进一步深究阿莉丝与“进程教会”之间可能存在的联系。他提出，她曾被一名教会成员从俾斯麦一路尾随到加利福尼亚，而这名男子就是她死前一天在工作场所与她争吵的人。特里将矛头指向“山姆之子”杀手大卫·伯克沃茨，认为他可能知道与该犯罪相关的关键信息。据特里称，在谋杀当晚，阿莉丝可能故意与布鲁斯吵架，因为这给了她一个要求
time alone to pray. Instead, she had planned to meet the mystery man from her past in the church. Even though authorities had dismissed rumors that Arliss's killing was satanic in nature, Terry remained convinced that it had been a ritualistic slaying. He pinpointed a series of caves behind Bismarck's University of Mary as a favoured ritual site for the process church, prompting locals to search the location for evidence. Due to the influx of visitors, the caves had to be filled in, which in turn caused the panic as people assumed it confirmed that a satanic cult was operating nearby. The book sent shockwaves throughout the Bismarck community. Local bookstores quickly
独处时间去祈祷的借口。相反，她计划在教堂里与她过去的神秘男子见面。尽管当局已经驳回了阿莉丝的遇害具有撒旦性质的传言，但特里仍然坚信这是一场仪式性的谋杀。他将俾斯麦玛丽大学后面的一系列洞穴锁定为“进程教会”青睐的仪式地点，促使当地人搜寻该地点以寻找证据。由于蜂拥而至的参观者，这些洞穴不得不被填平，这反过来又引起了恐慌，因为人们认为这证实了附近有撒旦邪教在活动。这本书在俾斯麦社区引起了轩然大波。当地书店迅速
sold out of their copies, and the library amassed a staggering waitlist, leading it to decrease its usual checkout time from four weeks to two weeks just to keep up with the demand. In the year after its release, the number of people on the waitlist stayed at about 50. In April of 1989, Maury Terry travelled to Bismarck to host a discussion about his book. The venue had to be changed at the last minute because the 1,000 capacity auditorium sold out, with lions circling around the block. Reverent Don de Coq, who had officiated Arliss's funeral, condemned the book, saying it offered no new information, but simply opened old wounds for her grieving family. Following his wife's murder, Bruce Perry took leave from Stanford
卖光了他们的藏书，图书馆积压了惊人的等待名单，导致它将通常的借阅时间从四周缩短为两周，仅仅为了满足需求。在其出版后的那一年里，等待名单上的人数一直保持在50人左右。1989年4月，莫里·特里前往俾斯麦主持一场关于他的书的讨论会。由于拥有1000个座位的礼堂门票售罄，场外排起了长龙，活动地点不得不临时更改。主持了阿莉丝葬礼的唐·德·考克牧师谴责了这本书，称它没有提供任何新信息，只是给悲痛的家人重新揭开了旧伤疤。在妻子被谋杀后，布鲁斯·佩里向斯坦福
University and spent the subsequent months visiting friends interstate who urged him to return to his studies. Bruce later told the Chicago reader newspaper, I had to get in control of what had happened instead of having the event control me. When anyone is traumatized, they've got to make that transition away from being a victim. Something had happened that was completely out of my control. I had to get away from feeling that because unpredictable, uncontrollable things happen, I might as well not do anything. He returned to Stanford and resumed his course, but was overwhelmed by the sympathy he received. He then transferred to Amherst College in Massachusetts and studied neuroscience,
大学请了假，并在随后的几个月里拜访了州外的友人，他们敦促他返回学业。布鲁斯后来对《芝加哥读者报》说：“我必须掌控发生的事情，而不是让事件掌控我。当任何人受到创伤时，他们都必须完成从受害者身份中抽离的转变。发生了一件完全超出我控制的事情。我必须摆脱那种因为发生不可预测、不可控的事情而认为自己干脆什么也不做的心态。”他回到斯坦福恢复了学业，但被收到的同情淹没了。随后，他转学到马萨诸塞州的阿默斯特学院学习神经科学，
eventually obtaining a degree in medicine. In 1984, Bruce undertook a residency in psychiatry at the prestigious Yale University, where he studied the brain chemistry of war veterans with major depression. He accepted a fellowship in child and adolescent psychology at the University of Chicago and became a renowned psychiatrist specializing in PTSD, trauma, and empathy, publishing two books on the matter. He also remarried and had children. In 1992, he reflected on the impact of Alice's murder to the Chicago reader, quote, I couldn't imagine anything worse to experience and I saw I could live through even this and be happy. I felt older. I felt free to be whatever I wanted to be. I thought about the external
最终获得了医学学位。1984年，布鲁斯在著名的耶鲁大学完成了精神病学住院医师实习期，在那里他研究了患有重度抑郁症的战争老兵的大脑化学。他在芝加哥大学接受了儿童和青少年心理学奖学金，并成为了一名专注于创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、创伤和同理心的知名精神病学家，发表了两本关于此事的书。他后来也再婚并有了孩子。1992年，他对《芝加哥读者报》反思了爱丽丝被害的影响，原话是：“我想象不出还有什么比这更糟糕的经历，我看到即使经历这一切我也能活下来并且感到快乐。我觉得自己更成熟了。我感到可以自由地成为我想成为的任何一个人。我想到了我们文化的外部
trappings of our culture and the things we value and don't value. I found that many of the things I cared about doing well at were really pretty empty. I put more effort into my relationships because I knew that's what's really enduring. Tests were carried out on the bloodstained shirt Bruce was wearing when police visited him the morning of Alice's murder. He claimed the blood was his own, sourced from a nosebleed, and results confirmed it didn't match Alice's blood type, nor did his palm print match the one on the altar candle. In 2004, any lingering suspicions that Bruce was responsible for Alice's death were finally put to rest when he submitted a DNA sample that proved conclusively he was not her killer.
浮华，以及我们重视和不重视的东西。我发现我曾经在乎要做好许多事情其实相当空洞。我把更多的精力投入到人际关系中，因为我知道那是真正持久的东西。”警方在爱丽丝遇害那天早晨拜访布鲁斯时，对布鲁斯身上穿的那件血衣进行了检测。他声称血迹是自己的，源于流鼻血，结果证实血迹与爱丽丝的血型不符，他的掌纹也与圣坛蜡烛上的掌纹不符。2004年，布鲁斯提交了一份DNA样本，最终确凿地证明他不是凶手，这彻底平息了关于他是爱丽丝被害元凶的挥之不去的怀疑。
In June 2016, an article published in the New York Post reported that a 64-year-old man named Bruce McCracken had come forward claiming he was in Stanford's Memorial Church on the night Alice Perry was killed. McCracken said he was walking past the church around midnight when he heard strange flute music coming from inside and entered to check it out. On the lectern, he saw a young, skinny white male whom he recognized as a member of Stanford's marching band. The male was wearing a light-colored Afro-style wig and playing a large silver flute. A young Caucasian woman was lying naked on the altar with candles burning on either side of her, looking upwards. The flutist didn't look happy to see McCracken, but the woman, who looked
2016年6月，《纽约邮报》发表了一篇文章称，一名叫布鲁斯·麦克拉肯的64岁男子主动站出来声称，在爱丽丝·佩里被杀的那晚，他就在斯坦福的纪念教堂里。麦克拉肯说，他在午夜左右路过教堂时，听到里面传出奇怪的长笛音乐，便进去查看。在讲台前，他看到一个年轻、消瘦的白人男性，他认出那是斯坦福行进乐队的成员。这个男子戴着一顶浅色阿弗罗风格的假发，吹着一把巨大的银色长笛。一个年轻的白人女性赤身裸体地躺在圣坛上，两边点着蜡烛，正向上看着。长笛手看到麦克拉肯似乎并不高兴，但那个看起来
very similar to Alice, turned her head towards him and smiled. Thinking they were playing some kind of game, McCracken left the church and didn't give it much thought. He later read about Alice Perry's murder, but failed to realize it had occurred the same night he interrupted the flute player and therefore never thought to report it to the police. Decades later, in 2011, while speaking to a retired police officer about strange things he had experienced while on the beat, Bruce remembered the incident at the Memorial Church. He searched online for a picture of Stanford's marching band from 1974, eventually finding a picture of the flutist. I finally saw his face and his eyes, those intense eyes. As soon as I saw the picture, I knew it was him.
与爱丽丝非常相似的女子却把头转向他并笑了笑。以为他们在玩某种游戏，麦克拉肯便离开了教堂，并没有多想。他后来读到了关于爱丽丝·佩里被谋杀的报道，却没有意识到这件事发生在打断长笛手的那天晚上，因此从未想过向警方报案。几十年后的2011年，在与一名退休警察交谈他在执勤时经历的奇怪事情时，布鲁斯记起了纪念教堂的那起事件。他在网上搜索了1974年斯坦福行进乐队的照片，最终找到了长笛手的照片。“我终于看到了他的脸和他的眼睛，那些强烈的眼神。一看到照片，我就知道是他。”
Bruce informed the Santa Clara County Sheriff's Department, and two detectives tracked down the flutist as he played a concert in Thousand Oaks, California. The detectives posed as reporters and arranged to meet the man under the guise of wanting to interview him about his career. The musician mentioned the Afro wig he had worn during his days in the Stanford marching band, confirming he had owned the hairpiece described by Bruce McCracken. He soon became suspicious and ended the interview, saying he would never return to perform in California again. A spokesperson for the Santa Clara Sheriff's Department maintained that the musician was not being considered a suspect, but would reevaluate his status should DNA evidence come to light.
布鲁斯将情况告知了圣克拉拉县治安官办公室，两名侦探追踪到了这名正在加利福尼亚州千橡市一场音乐会上表演的长笛手。侦探们伪装成记者，以想采访他的职业生涯为由安排与该男子会面。这位音乐家提到了他曾在斯坦福行进乐队期间戴过的阿弗罗假发，证实他确实拥有布鲁斯·麦克拉肯所描述的假发。他很快起了疑心并结束了采访，称他再也不会回到加利福尼亚演出。圣克拉拉治安官办公室的一位发言人坚称，该音乐家并未被视为嫌疑人，但如果有DNA证据浮出水面，他们将重新评估其身份。
When confronted by the New York Post, the unnamed musician vehemently denied any involvement in Arliss's murder, quote, I've never been involved in anything criminal in my entire life. I've been very lucky that way. As forensic testing technology advanced over the years, items recovered from the Arliss Perry crime scene were routinely reanalyzed by the County Crime Lab. In 2016, in a much needed breakthrough, they located the DNA profile of an unknown male on the jeans Arliss had been wearing on the night of her death. Over the next two years, police from the Santa Clara County Sheriff's Office tracked down and re-interviewed everyone who was in the vicinity of Stanford's Memorial Church on the night of Sunday, October 12, 1974, obtaining fingerprints and DNA samples from each.
当被《纽约邮报》质问时，这位未透露姓名的音乐家坚决否认与阿莉丝的谋杀有任何牵连，原话是：“我一生中从未参与过任何犯罪活动。我在这方面一直很幸运。”随着法医检测技术在多年间的进步，从阿莉丝·佩里犯罪现场回收的物品被县犯罪实验室例行重新分析。2016年，在一个急需的突破中，他们在阿莉丝在遇害当晚穿的牛仔裤上找到了一个未知男性的DNA图谱。在接下来的两年里，圣克拉拉县治安官办公室的警察追踪并重新讯问了1974年10月12日星期日晚上在斯坦福纪念教堂附近的所有人，获取了每个人的指纹和DNA样本。
They ruled them out one by one, leaving just one possible suspect remaining. Former Stanford night watchman Stephen Blake Crawford was now 72 years old and in poor health. He lived alone in San Jose, approximately 25 miles from the university, surviving on social security and his leftover retirement funds. He had remained a person of interest in the Arliss Perry investigation over the years, but he had passed a polygraph. His palm print didn't match the one found on an altar candle used in her attack, and with no further evidence or motive to link him to the crime, police had no grounds to make an arrest. They kept in contact with Crawford, occasionally re-interviewing him, but nothing ever surfaced that implicated him.
他们一个接一个地排除了这些人，只剩下一个可能的嫌疑人。前斯坦福夜间看守斯蒂芬·布莱克·克劳福德当时已经72岁，健康状况不佳。他独自住在圣何塞，距离大学大约25英里，靠社会保障和剩余的退休基金过活。多年来，他一直是阿莉丝·佩里调查中的嫌疑人，但他通过了测谎仪。他的掌纹与她的袭击中使用的圣坛蜡烛上发现的掌纹不符，并且由于没有进一步的证据或动机将他与犯罪联系起来，警方没有逮捕他的理由。他们与克劳福德保持联系，偶尔重新讯问他，但从未浮现任何暗示他涉案的线索。
Crawford had served in the US Air Force before working as a police officer for Stanford University's Department of Public Safety. In 1971, the department underwent a drastic reduction following the appointment of a new police chief. 75% of staff lost their jobs, including Crawford. He was forced to hand in his gun and was reappointed as a night watch campus security guard, a demotion that he bitterly complained about. He held the job until 1976, before leaving to work security elsewhere. Members of a square dance group Crawford belonged to nicknamed him the Prevaricator, for his habit of lying and exaggerating stories. In one instance, he told them his parents died
克劳福德曾在美国空军服役，之后在斯坦福大学公共安全部担任警官。1971年，在任命了新的警察局长后，该部门经历了一次激烈的裁员。75%的员工失去了工作，包括克劳福德。他被迫交出配枪，并被重新任命为夜间校园保安，这是一次令他怨声载道的降职。他一直干这份工作到1976年，之后离开去别处从事安保工作。克劳福德所属的一个方块舞团的成员给他起了个绰号叫“诡辩者”，因为他爱撒谎和夸大其词。有一次，他告诉他们，他的父母在他很小的时候在车祸中双双身亡，而实际上，他们是在他二十岁出头时分别在不同的事故中去世的。
in a car crash when he was young, when in reality, they died in separate incidents when he was in his early twenties. In 1992, Crawford's ex-wife reported him for forging a fake diploma using a blank certificate he had stolen from Stanford University. A search of his home revealed he had also stolen up to 300 rare and valuable books from the university library, including leather-bound Latin texts dating back to the 16th century, as well as priceless photos and artifacts from the Department of Anthropology. Among the items were a cane belonging to the university's founder Leland Stanford and a skull. When asked why he stole the items, Crawford said he simply liked old things and took them in retaliation for being considered a suspect in the Alice Perry murder.
1992年，克劳福德的前妻举报他伪造假文凭，使用的是他从斯坦福大学偷来的一张空白证书。对他的家进行的搜查显示，他还从大学图书馆偷了多达300本珍贵稀有的书籍，包括可以追溯到16世纪的皮革装订拉丁语文本，以及来自人类学部门的无价照片和文物。其中的物品中还有一根属于大学创始人利兰·斯坦福的手杖和一个头骨。当被问及为什么要偷这些东西时，克劳福德说他只是喜欢老旧的东西，拿它们是为了报复自己被视为爱丽丝·佩里谋杀案的嫌疑人。
Given the books were valued in the hundreds of thousands of dollars, the theft was considered a felony. Crawford pleaded guilty to receiving stolen property and was given a six-month suspended sentence with two years probation. He began working as an insurance adjuster and lived a quiet, somewhat reclusive life, having no further run-ins with the law. On the morning of Thursday, June 28, 2018, detectives arrived at Crawford's ground floor studio apartment to place him under arrest and execute a search warrant in the hopes of gathering further evidence to link him to Alice Perry's murder. When they knocked on the front door, Crawford told them to wait a moment while he got dressed. After several minutes,
鉴于这些书籍价值数十万美元，这起偷窃被视为重罪。克劳福德对收受赃物罪名认罪，被判处六个月缓刑和两年缓刑。他开始做保险理赔员，过着平静、甚至有些离群索居的生活，再也没有触犯过法律。2018年6月28日星期四早晨，侦探们抵达克劳福德位于一楼的单间公寓，准备将他逮捕并执行搜查令，希望能搜集到更多将他与爱丽丝·佩里谋杀案联系起来的证据。当他们敲前门时，克劳福德让他们等一会儿，他穿个衣服。几分钟后，
the detectives suspected he was intentionally stalling and let themselves in using a master key they had obtained from the building's manager. Inside, they confronted Crawford, who was sitting on his bed holding a handgun. The detectives immediately retreated and moments later, the sound of a gunshot rang out. Crawford was found on the floor with a self-inflicted gunshot wound to his head. A search of his apartment uncovered the dust jacket from a hardback copy of Maury Terry's 1987 book The Ultimate Evil in a folder with other papers. On a computer table a foot away from the bed was a hastily written suicide note dated two years earlier, indicating he had expected this moment for quite some time. The note was difficult to read
侦探们怀疑他是在故意拖延，便用从大楼经理那里拿到的总钥匙自行进入。在里面，他们与坐在床上手拿手枪的克劳福德对峙。侦探们立刻撤退，片刻之后，传出了一声枪响。克劳福德被发现倒在地板上，头部有自己开枪造成的伤口。对他的公寓进行的搜查在装有其他文件的文件夹中发现了一本莫里·特里1987年出版的书《终极邪恶》精装版的护封。距离床一英尺的一个电脑桌上放着一封字迹潦草的自杀信，落款日期是两年前，表明他相当长一段时间以来一直预料到了这一刻。这封信很难读懂，
and made no mention of Alice, but coincided with a time period when detectives recommenced interrogating Crawford in relation to her murder. It was suspected that he had targeted Alice to exact revenge against Stanford University following his demotion years earlier. Stephen Crawford's DNA was compared to the DNA of Alice Perry's killer, resulting in a match, and the 44-year-old unsolved case was finally closed. That afternoon, police held a press conference to announce the news, with Sheriff Laurie Smith thanking the cold case detectives for their unrelenting work in solving the decades-old crime and finally obtaining closure for Alice's family.
也没有提到爱丽丝，但却与侦探们重新开始就她被谋杀一事审讯克劳福德的时间段不谋而合。人们怀疑他当年是为了报复斯坦福大学的降职而将爱丽丝作为袭击目标的。斯蒂芬·克劳福德的DNA与爱丽丝·佩里凶手的DNA进行了比对，结果吻合，这起悬了44年的案件终于告破。那天下午，警方举行了记者招待会宣布这一消息，治安官劳里·史密斯感谢未破案件侦探们为破获这起几十年前的犯罪所做的不懈努力，并最终为爱丽丝的家人讨回了公道。
Standing alongside an enlarged photograph of Alice, Sheriff Smith told the assembled reporters, this is a case that eludes us no longer. Lead detective Sergeant Richard Alanis kept this picture of Alice Perry with him as a constant reminder that her life and this case had value. Alice's sister Karen said she had no doubt the police would solve the case one day and wasn't surprised to learn that Crawford was the killer, as his story had changed throughout the years and he was a known liar. Alice's father Marvin had passed away three and a half months prior to the breakthrough. Her mother Jean, who was now 88 years old, was heartbroken that her husband had died without ever knowing who had killed their daughter, as he had been desperate to
站在爱丽丝放大的照片旁，史密斯治安官对聚集的记者说：“这是一个不再与我们擦肩而过的案件。”首席侦探理查德·阿拉尼斯中士一直把这张爱丽丝·佩里的照片带在身边，以此时刻提醒自己她的生命和这个案件是有价值的。爱丽丝的妹妹凯伦说，她毫不怀疑警方总有一天会破案，得知克劳福德是凶手也并不感到惊讶，因为他的故事多年来一直在变，而且他是个众所周知的骗子。爱丽丝的父亲马尔文在案件破获前三个半月就已经去世了。现年88岁的母亲让则心碎不已，因为她的丈夫至死也不知道是谁杀害了他们的女儿，他曾极其渴望
find out the truth. Taking comfort in her religious beliefs, Jean said, I know there is someone far greater that will punish this person. I don't have to do that. Alice Perry's cold case file had long been associated with the unsolved murder of Leslie Perlov and Janet Taylor. Due to the similarities between crime scenes, many suspected Leslie, Janet and Alice had fallen victim to the same killer, though they were never formally linked. Santa Clara County Sheriff Laurie Smith initially stated that although investigators did not think Stephen Crawford was connected to any other unsolved local homicides, they left the possibility open. Quote, In homicides, even cold cases, we have a warehouse
找出真相。从宗教信仰中寻求慰藉，让说道：“我知道有一个更伟大的人会惩罚这个人。我没有必要去这么做。”爱丽丝·佩里的悬案档案长期以来一直与莱斯利·佩洛夫和珍妮特·泰勒未破的谋杀案联系在一起。由于犯罪现场之间的相似性，许多人怀疑莱斯利、珍妮特和爱丽丝都是同一个凶手的受害者，尽管她们从未被正式联系起来。圣克拉拉县治安官劳里·史密斯最初表示，尽管调查人员认为斯蒂芬·克劳福德与任何其他未破获的当地凶杀案无关，但他们仍然保留了这种可能性。原话是：“在凶杀案中，即使是悬案，我们也有一个证据仓库。
of evidence. We keep the evidence for life, even when there's a conviction. Forensic evidence collected from Leslie Perlov's crime scene was submitted for re-analysis, and that too resulted in a key DNA discovery. The evidence was sourced from underneath Leslie's fingernails and was a mismatch for Stephen Crawford, ruling out the possibility that Alice and Leslie's murders were carried out by the same perpetrator. Using similar methods that helped identify the alleged Golden State killer in April 2018, detectives sent the sample off to Parabon Nano Labs, a Virginia-based medical lab that combines DNA testing with the genealogical databases to map an unknown suspect to their relatives and
我们会终身保留证据，即使已经定罪。”从莱斯利·佩洛夫犯罪现场收集的法医证据被送去重新分析，这也带来了关键的DNA发现。这些证据采集自莱斯利的指甲缝下，与斯蒂芬·克劳福德不匹配，从而排除了爱丽丝和莱斯利的谋杀案是由同一凶手实施的可能性。利用帮助识别2018年4月所谓“金州杀手”的类似方法，侦探们将样本送到了Parabon Nano Labs，这是一家总部位于弗吉尼亚州的医学实验室，它将DNA检测与家谱数据库结合起来，将未知嫌疑人与其亲属和祖先联系起来。
ancestors. They matched the DNA sample with members belonging to the Getru family, prompting investigators to search through the Getru family tree to identify someone whose history aligned with the circumstances surrounding Leslie's murder. In 1973, John Arthur Getru worked as a medical technician in Stanford University's campus hospital in the heart transplant unit. Getru had a violent criminal history dating back to 1963, when his family were stationed in Germany for his father's work with the United States military. On the evening of June 8, 18-year-old Getru encountered 15-year-old Margot Williams, the daughter of the Army chaplain, as she was leaving a church dance on base. The following morning, Margot was found strangled and raped in
他们将DNA样本与属于格特鲁家族的成员相匹配，促使调查人员在格特鲁家族树中寻找历史与莱斯利谋杀案周围情况相吻合的人。1973年，约翰·亚瑟·格特鲁在斯坦福大学校园医院的心脏移植部门担任医学技术员。格特鲁有着可以追溯到1963年的暴力犯罪史，当时他的家人因父亲在美国军方工作而驻扎在德国。6月8日傍晚，18岁的格特鲁遇到了15岁的玛戈·威廉姆斯，她是陆军牧师的女儿，当时她正离开基地的一场教堂舞会。次日清晨，玛戈被发现遭到强奸，并被勒死在教堂后面的田野里。
a field behind the church. Getru was identified as a suspect immediately, and his arrest soon followed. He admitted to the crime in court, stating, I raped her, but it did not occur to me that I could have killed her. I just wanted to knock her out. He was convicted and sentenced to 10 years in prison. Yet, because he was a foreigner and considered a juvenile under German law, the court said that he could be released on parole after serving two years and returned to America. By 1972, Getru was living and working in Palo Alto as a security guard for California Plant Protection Services. His criminal past was a secret to those around him. In 1975, two years after Leslie Perlov was murdered, Getru targeted a 17-year-old member
格特鲁立即被确认为嫌疑人，并很快被捕。他在法庭上承认了罪行，并说道：“我强奸了她，但我没想到我会杀了她。我只是想把她打晕。”他被定罪并被判处10年监禁。然而，由于他是外国人且根据德国法律被视为未成年人，法庭称他在服刑两年后可以假释并返回美国。到1972年，格特鲁在帕洛阿尔托生活和工作，担任加州植物保护服务的保安。他的犯罪过去对周围的人来说是个秘密。1975年，在莱斯利·佩洛夫被谋杀两年后，格特鲁盯上了帕洛阿尔托一名17岁的童军探险队成员。
of the Scouts Explorer troupe in Palo Alto. Getru became involved in the group as a scout leader, taking the children to dances and other events while acting as their guardian. He had befriended his latest victim over a six-month period and on the night of January 19, arrived at her home while her parents were not there. After talking to her for about two hours, Getru pushed her under the couch and began assaulting her. When she threatened to cry out for help, he put his hand around her neck and squeezed, threatening, don't do that. I have my hand at your throat and I could hurt you. Getru pleaded guilty to statutory rape and was sentenced to six-months jail, five of which were suspended. He was ordered to pay a $200 fine and served his remaining 30
格特鲁作为童军领袖参与了该组织，带领孩子们参加舞会和其他活动，同时充当他们的监护人。他在长达六个月的时间里与他的最新受害者交好，并于1月19日晚在她父母不在家时来到了她家。在同她交谈了大约两个小时后，格特鲁把她推到沙发底下并开始侵犯她。当她威胁要呼救时，他把手放在她的脖子上并用力掐住，威胁道：“别那样。我的手在你的喉咙上，我可以伤害你。”格特鲁对法定强奸罪名认罪，被判处六个月监禁，其中五个月缓刑。他被勒令支付200美元罚款，并在周末服完了剩下的30天刑期。
days in jail on weekends. John Getru's DNA was obtained from items he discarded and was compared to evidence recovered from the Leslie Perlov crime scene. Not only was there a match, the subsequent DNA report stated, The probability that a random, unrelated individual could be included as a possible contributor to this deduced profile was approximately one in 65 septillion. This figure would be the number 65 followed by 24 zeros. On November 20, 2018, the now 74-year-old grandfather, carpenter and scout leader was placed under arrest at his home in Haywood, approximately 21 miles from Stanford and charged with the first-degree murder of Leslie Perlov. Over the past 45 years, cold case detectives
约翰·格特鲁的DNA是从他丢弃的物品中提取的，并与从莱斯利·佩洛夫犯罪现场恢复的证据进行了比对。不仅完全吻合，随后的DNA报告还指出：“一个随机的、无血缘关系的个人作为可能贡献者被包含在这个推导图谱中的概率大约是一分之65万京。”这个数字将是65后面跟着24个零。2018年11月20日，这位现年74岁的祖父、木匠兼童军领袖在距离斯坦福约21英里的海沃德家中被捕，并被控一级谋杀莱斯利·佩洛夫。在过去的45年里，悬案侦探们
had remained in touch with the Perlov family, updating them on their efforts to find Leslie's killer. As the eldest of three children, Leslie was regarded as her sibling's protector. She had once shared a bedroom with her sister Diane and the pair traded clothes, secrets and laughter. When she left for Stanford, Diane had cried. Leslie's brother Craig told the media, I still miss Leslie. She was a brilliant, kind and loving person. Leslie's mother Florence had died four years earlier and never sought grief counseling as she felt the hole in her heart could never heal. In November 2018, Diane received a call from a detective sergeant informing her, we got him. She attended Gertrude's bail hearing that same
一直与佩洛夫家族保持联系，向他们通报寻找莱斯利凶手的进展。作为三个孩子中的老大，莱斯利被视为她兄弟姐妹的保护者。她曾与妹妹黛安共用一个卧室，两人交换衣服、秘密和欢笑。当她离开去斯坦福时，黛安哭了。莱斯利的兄弟克雷格对媒体说：“我依然想念莱斯利。她是一个聪明、善良和充满爱心的人。”莱斯利的母亲弗洛伦斯在四年前就去世了，生前从未寻求过哀伤辅导，因为她觉得心里的空洞永远无法愈合。2018年11月，黛安接到了一位侦探中士的电话，通知她：“我们抓到他了。”她在同月的格特鲁保释听证会上出席，
month and pleaded to the court that he'd be denied bail. Diane looked directly at Gertrude, who steadfastly averted his gaze and told him the scarf tied around Leslie's neck that day was mine. Diane went on to explain how she could no longer walk alone in the woods, wear a scarf or let anyone touch her neck. Quote, I want you to know that murder does not just affect the deceased. It changes many lives. It takes many lives and impacts a family forever. And while justice doesn't heal all wounds, it is the least we can do. The presiding judge agreed with Diane and refused Gertrude bail, instead ordering that he be held in the Santa Clara County Jail to await trial.
并向法庭恳求拒绝给予他保释。黛安直视着格特鲁，而格特鲁始终避开她的目光，并告诉他那条那天系在莱斯利脖子上的围巾是我的。黛安接着解释了她为什么再也不能独自在树林里散步、戴围巾或让任何人触碰她的脖子。原话是：“我想让你知道，谋杀不仅仅影响死者。它改变了许多生命。它夺走了许多生命，并永远影响着一个家庭。虽然正义无法治愈所有的创伤，但这是我们所能做的最起码的事情。”主审法官同意了黛安的意见，拒绝了格特鲁的保释，转而下令将他关押在圣克拉拉县监狱等待审判。
While Gertrude was in custody, clothing belonging to Janet Taylor was also re-submitted for a more thorough forensic examination, and semen staining was discovered within a torn seam in the crotch of the green corduroy pants she was wearing at the time of her death. The DNA profile obtained from the staining was found to have a 1 in 34,800 chance of coming from anyone but John Gertrude. On May 16, 2019, Gertrude was also charged with Janet Taylor's murder. In a statement, Janet's family said, Janet lived life with enthusiasm and courage. As a spunky, fun-loving, youngest of three children, she added much laughter and joy to our family. She loved animals and
在格特鲁德被拘留期间，珍妮特·泰勒的衣物也被重新送检，以进行更彻底的法医检查。在其遇害时穿的绿色灯芯绒裤子的裆部撕裂缝隙中，发现了精液斑。从斑迹中提取的DNA图谱显示，除了约翰·格特鲁德之外，来自其他人的概率为34800分之一。2019年5月16日，格特鲁德也被指控谋杀珍妮特·泰勒。珍妮特的家人在一份声明中表示，珍妮特以热情和勇气度过了她的一生。作为家中三个孩子中最小的一个，她性格活泼、热爱生活，为我们的家庭增添了许多欢笑和快乐。她热爱动物，
cherished her friends. We have missed being able to have her in our lives. Janet's future was bright. It would have been wonderful to see what she would have done. We can't ever know all that we missed, but whatever she pursued, Janet would have served others with passion and kindness. We're grateful today for the diligent, meticulous work of the law enforcement officers whose efforts have resulted in today's announcement. They've done this difficult work with integrity and excellence and with compassion for our family. Gertrude has pleaded not guilty to wall charges and is currently awaiting trial.
珍惜她的朋友。我们一直无比怀念她在我们生活中的日子。珍妮特的未来本是一片光明。如果能看到她后来的成就，那该有多好。我们永远无法知晓我们错过了多少，但无论她追求什么，珍妮特都会以热情和善良服务他人。今天，我们对执法人员勤勉、细致的工作表示感激，正是他们的努力促成了今天的公告。他们以诚信、卓越以及对我们家人的同情完成了这项艰难的工作。格特鲁德对所有指控均表示不认罪，目前正在等待审判。
He will be held to penalties in effect at the time of the murders, with the maximum sentence for homicide in the early 70s being seven years to life. Given his age and the amount of time that has lapsed since the crimes, court officials are prioritizing his cases. He will first stand trial for Leslie Perlov's murder in September 2020. John Getru is also being investigated as a suspect in other run-solved crimes. Senator Clara County Sheriff Laurie Smith expects that the modern DNA techniques used to capture Stephen Crawford and John Getru will help solve the 100-plus cold cases in the county dating back to 1946. Quote,
他将受到谋杀发生时生效的法律惩罚，70年代初谋杀罪的最高刑期为七年到无期徒刑。鉴于他的年龄以及罪行发生以来所经过的时间，法院官员正在优先处理他的案件。他将首先于2020年9月因谋杀莱斯利·佩洛夫而受审。约翰·格特鲁也在作为嫌疑人接受其他未破案件的调查。克拉拉参议员县治安官劳里·史密斯希望，用于抓获斯蒂芬·克劳福德和约翰·格特鲁的现代DNA技术，能够帮助破获该县自1946年以来100多起未破悬案。引述：
Because we have this technology, we want to hit all of these cases while the suspects are still alive. Shortly after Arliss was murdered, Bruce Perry spoke of his late wife to the Chicago Reader. Quote, I had long periods of pain and sadness and of thinking how unfair it seemed. I tried to think about what it was that would make a human being do this. There was a lot of anger initially, but I didn't know where to direct it, since I didn't know what exactly had happened. You sort of had to make something up to get angry at. Then I just quit doing that. It was getting in the way of me being able to move on.
因为我们拥有这项技术，我们希望在嫌疑人仍然健在的时候，攻克所有这些案件。在阿利斯遇害后不久，布鲁斯·佩里曾向《芝加哥读者报》谈及他已故的妻子。引述，我有过很长的痛苦和悲伤时期，觉得这一切是多么不公平。我试图去思考究竟是什么能让一个人做出这种事。最初有很多愤怒，但我不知道该把愤怒发泄到哪里，因为我不知道究竟发生了什么。你不得不凭空捏造一个对象来发泄愤怒。后来我不再这样做了。这妨碍了我继续生活。
When I accepted the fact that death was a part of life, it did not matter that much anymore what the person who killed her looked like or was like. Bruce Perry is currently a senior fellow of the Child Trauma Academy in Houston, Texas, and an adjunct professor in psychiatry and behavioral sciences at Chicago's Feinberg School of Medicine. He has worked as a consultant with the FBI on many high-profile cases involving traumatized children and has appeared on the Oprah Winfrey show speaking about how adverse early experiences can lead to physical and mental challenges later in life. He believes his ordeal helps him identify and empathize with his patients.
当我接受死亡是生命一部分的事实后，杀死她的人长什么样或是什么样，就已经不那么重要了。布鲁斯·佩里目前是德克萨斯州休斯顿儿童创伤研究所的高级研究员，也是芝加哥范伯格医学院精神病学和行为科学系的兼职教授。他曾担任联邦调查局的顾问，参与许多涉及受创伤儿童的高调案件，并曾登上奥普拉·温弗瑞秀，谈论早期的逆境如何导致日后的身心挑战。他相信自己的苦难经历有助于他识别并理解他的患者，产生同理心。
Arliss Perry was late to rest at the Sunset Memorial Gardens in her hometown of Bismarck. On the day of her funeral, Reverend Donda Koch told the gathering of 300 mourners. Somebody is going to say that Arliss didn't have a chance to learn what life is all about. On the contrary, Arliss knew exactly what life is all about. That it is full of joy and full of sorrow, of victory and trials, and that man is a mere breath, his days like a passing shadow. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
阿利斯·佩里被安葬在她家乡俾斯麦的日落纪念花园里。在她葬礼的那天，唐达·科奇牧师对聚集的300名哀悼者说。总有人会说阿利斯没有机会了解生活究竟是怎么一回事。恰恰相反，阿利斯非常清楚生活究竟是怎么一回事。那就是生活充满了欢乐与悲伤、胜利与考验，人不过是一缕气息，他的日子如同逝去的阴影。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。